and guess what everybody hot off the
press what she responded
let's serve up some news sunny side up
first step two of our favorite love
birds i mean i know it's happening it's
everywhere i'm so happy for them people
reports the machine gun kelly were
proposed to none other than his love
megan fox and she said
we love this
and
you know
machine gun kelly came on this show and
really did us a solid by saying hey i
just want to come here and like peel
back the layers and keep it real and we
love him so much for it
and um he talked about megan and you
know how she calms him yeah and the
beautiful way she handles him
supports him loves him
uh and here they are yeah they official
i was so sweet the way he talked about
her and i love their relationship and
the fact that you know they put a ring
on it it's so sweet they did celebrate
in a very interesting way though did you
hear yeah tell me what it said because i
read it too but i want to know your take
rossi well all i know is that it said
that after the proposal that they
drank each other's blood
which i think is you know uh if i good
for you i'm very happy would you have
you what do you
not for me i'm
i'm more of like a chocolate milk kind
of guy
i don't know you don't want wellie's uh
blood you'd rather have a yoo-hoo
ding-dong i'll take it you could have
had a v8
could have had to be yeah totally you
know what's weird is the way i read it
actually was like a joke i took it as a
like a cutie wink like we're all giving
you something to talk about we're just
messing with you okay i don't know but
you never know
first step in the news we've all been
celebrating the life of the american
comedy legend betty white
and now the miami herald reports that a
new campaign
is spreading in her honor it's called
the betty white challenge and on january
17th which would be her 100th birthday
fans are donating five dollars to an
animal charity of their choice in
betty's name or
going and actually adopting an animal
and betty always said
that if she wasn't in show business
she'd be a zookeeper what if you adopt
one and name it betty
that's the best thing we have ever
there's gonna be like a million little
kitties and puppies named betty just
running around and she would love that
next up new year new you it's the start
of 2022 what new habits do you want to
create in your life well buzzfeed
reports that reese witherspoon shared
her 2022 tips and she got a great
response from none other than ina garten
that's right on reese's list was a big
glass of water every day 10 minutes of
daylight in the morning an hour of
reading and an early bedtime at 10 with
no late night tv
to that aina responded with her list
more large
cosmos more late night screaming more
staying in bed to play sudoku in the
morning and finally lots of time with
the people you love
so
of course i had to get on the phone and
text reese witherspoon and see if i
could get a little tidbit from her and
guess what everybody hot off the press
what she responded oh my gosh hi
yeah i love this
just now okay
rhys says aina garten is the queen of
all things listen to her not me with a
cute emoji
i love that
first up we love digging into the latest
terms and trends in dating and we've got
a new one for you for the new year the
independent reports dating apps say
power pda is officially a thing
and it's not just for the megan foxes
and machine gun kelly's of the world
seventy percent of daters globally say
they're more open to public a smooching
mm-hmm
frosty
what
thought
i
listen i you know who i don't like the
people who say get a room you know why
because you go get a room and sit by
yourself and be lonely
i think
we are
we are so lucky if you have love in your
life you know
to to show it and you remember those
first few months of a relationship where
you just can't get enough like if people
are in that zone don't reign on their
parade don't let them have that we need
more love in the world
next up we've got an interesting job
opportunity i love this story i brought
this to the news desk food and wine
reports that peel island a small island
off the coast of england is looking for
someone to run its pub oh and double as
its king
the position has been filled for over
300 years and there are no other
permanent residents on the island so
whoever applies should have a strong
passion for isolation peace and quiet
well i think we've been set up for
success here um the inauguration
involves wearing a helmet and holding a
sword while buckets of beer are dumped
on your head sounds like the super bowl
meets vikings um and then people come
and do like day trips on the island but
you run a pub yeah and you're the king
roy thoughts
[Laughter]
why has got to be beer why can't it be
whiskey i prefer whiskey if i'm the king
i should decide what you dump on my head
finally we have a pick from drew's
little yellow book oh yes that's right
it is
my personal curation that i work with
everyone on the show with because i
think that if i was a professional
curator i would be happy
so we refresh it every single week we're
very thoughtful about it we do all the
pics ourselves and this week i'm excited
because i did a social post about this
and it just brings me to nostalgia city
i just seen spider-man
and has anyone seen spider-man here i
hear it's so great it is so good and it
is about the power of three
and which takes me back to the best time
a
you know girl could ever have and that
was being one of
three with the charlie's angels so
flower beauty made this flower beauty x
charlie's angels palette which is now
available exclusively with our beauty
partners at cvs and you can get it on
flowerbeauty.com
and it looks like a dvd and there's all
these treats with it and uh the colors
are like angel's eyes
which is what tom green called me in the
movie i liked it so much i married him
speaking of there's the chad dylan good
morning angels independent women hey
i will never forget being in the trailer
and we we heard the demo from destiny's
child come in uh i just heard that song
the other day and i was like drew that's
you
you get a shout out and that's what does
that get
low with my girl drew cameron d and
destiny charlie's angels
[Music]